à 1500 nous déplorons 76 1507 décès au
total dans le monde et les pays les plus
touchés sont l'italie 16500 23 morts
l'espagne 13 1798 décès et les états
unis avec plus de 11 mille morts en
france selon les données hospitalières
de plus de 1000 établissements qui
démontre ce soir l'impact sévère du
virus et de l'épidémie trente mille
personnes sont actuellement hospitalisés
pour une infection à kovy 19
c'est encore un solde de 305 personnes
supplémentaires admise à l'hôpital au
cours des 24 dernières heures
sept mille cent trente et une personnes
en situations graves nécessitent des
soins lourds en réanimation sont des
formes graves chez des adultes puisque
34 % des patients hospitalisés ont moins
de 60 ans et que 61 % d'entre eux ont
entre 60 et 80 ans il y à aussi 104
personnes hospitalisées en réanimation
est âgée de moins de 30 ans au cours des
dernières 24 heures ce sont 500 18
nouveaux cas graves qui ont été admis en
réanimation mais finalement il n'a été
nécessaire prendre en charge que 59
patients supplémentaires
lorsqu'on tient compte des sorties
quotidiennes qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses
ce besoin de trouver de nouvelles places
augmentent moins rapidement 94 nouvelle
place hier 140 dimanche
176 samedi 263 vendredi ce solde de
patients supplémentaires à prendre en
charge chaque jour reste cependant
positif et donc c'est l'indicateur que
l'épidémie continue sa progression et
c'est aussi un indicateur important de
tensions dans les établissements de
santé et de mobilisation absolue totale
des ressources humaines et logistiques
dans les outre-mer ou hadoop guyane
réunion martinique mayotte on relève 145
hospitalisations contre 163 hier dont 44
en réanimation et cent soixante et une
personnes guéries rentrée à domicile
donc avec plus de sorties que deux
personnes hospitalisées
le total des personnes guéries dix neuf
mille trois cent trente sept personnes
sorties de l'hôpital depuis l'épidémie
depuis le début d'épidémie augmentent
chaque jour et il faut y ajouter je leur
ai je le répète les dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui sont guéris en ville et
qui n'ont pas eu besoin
d'hospitalisation en ce qui concerne la
surveillance syndromique en populations
en ville
les services d'urgence ont enseigné 3195
passage hier c'est 15% de leurs
activités nous observons 40%
d'hospitalisation après ses passages aux
urgences et trois adultes 5 pour cent en
réanimation
925 intervention de sos médecins ont été
nécessaires et hier c'est moins que pour
la journée de dimanche puisque ce
chiffre était de 1055 et ses 7 % de
l'activité totale de sos médecins pour
les laboratoires 59 1398 tests ont été
réalisés par ce réseau de laboratoires
de villes dont 16 1489 sont positifs
soit un bilan de 28 % de positivité
candombe l'on comparé le taux de
positivité entre l'hôpital et la ville
il est de 40 2% de positif à l'hôpital
et de 23% en ville vous savez que nous
sommes extrêmement attentifs à la
situation dans les établissements
sociaux et médico-sociaux ce soir 4553
établissements dont 2958 ehpad
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes ont signalé
un épisode concernant un ou plusieurs
cas de kovy de 19 à santé publique
france à travers l'application du
portail nationale de signalement
les signalements donne donc un total de
30 1902 cas de covile 19 confirmés ou
possible sur toute la période épidémique
donc depuis le premier
en ce qui concerne le bilan des décès la
première source et la mortalité
hospitalière
depuis le 1er mars nous déplorons 7091
décès 82 % de ces décès surviennent chez
des personnes de plus de 70 ans
on note 14 décès en outre-mer 8 en
guadeloupe 4 en martinique de à mayotte
dans les dernières 24 heures un total de
607 décès a été enregistré en milieu
hospitalier
en ce qui concerne la mortalité au sein
des ehpad ou des établissements médico
sociaux
nous déplorons 3237 décès survenus
depuis le début de l'épidémie et donc la
hausse observée aujourd'hui 820 décès en
plus est liée aussi à un probable retard
de saisie et au fait que nous sortons
d'un week end
depuis le 1er mars
en additionnant les décès survenus à
l'hôpital et ceux survenus au sein des
établissements médico sociaux et en
particulier les ehpad
nous déplorons 10300 28 décès à
l'échelon national
l'excès de mortalité se stabilise avec
une hausse de 15% sur la semaine 12 et
un excès de 30 % sur la semaine 13 à
l'échelon régional
l'excès de mortalité est observée dans
cinq régions en semaine douze et six
régions en semaine 13 grand test île de
france bourgogne franche comté auvergne
rhône-alpes au de france et centre val
de loire avec un excès important en
grand test et en ile-de-france et
émergent dans trois régions en semaine
14 ile-de-france grand test et bourgogne
franche comté à l'échelon départemental
30 départements et présente un excès de
mortalité en semaine 13 et 22
départements présentent déjà un excès de
mortalité pour la semaine 14 4
départements
sont en excès exceptionnelle selon
l'insee et santé publique france les
départements du haut-rhin de paris de la
seine saint denis et du val d'oise les
excès concernent majoritairement des
personnes de plus de 65 ans enfin santé
publique france estime que 78 milles 167
tests ont été confirmés par test pcr
soit 3777 cas de plus nous sommes
aujourd'hui le 7 avril
et c'est la journée mondiale de la santé
cette année elle a lieu dans un contexte
on ne peut plus particulier qui nous
rappelle plus que jamais l'importance du
personnel soignant
n'ayant pas peur du terme ils sont de
véritables héros nos véritables héros
qu'on ne peut qu'applaudir tous les
soirs face à la crise le défi est
immense
et pourtant même en ces temps très
difficiles il arrive à accomplir des
choses merveilleuses sauver des vies
celle de nos proches de nos familles de
nos amis mais aussi sourire rassuré et
apaisé durant cette pandémie
nous savons leur manifester notre
gratitude
tous les soirs de jour comme de nuit
leur mobilisation est totale notre
gratitude l'est tout autant
vous le savez le système de santé est
fortement mobilisée depuis le début de
cette épidémie pour répondre aux besoins
de prise en charge des patients atteints
par le virus
cela ne doit pas faire oublier le fait
que certains soins et examens doivent
impérativement être maintenue tant en
ville qu'à l'hôpital car ils sont
indispensables pour la bonne santé de la
population
je pense aux patients qui sont atteints
d'une maladie chronique et qui ont
besoin d'être suivis régulièrement aux
patients qui ont un suivi psychiatrique
ou encore aux patients qui ont une
réelle indication d'interventions
chirurgicales urgentes
je veux ce soir les rassurer et leur
dire que les structures de soins se sont
organisés de façon à proposer des
circuits de prise en charge dédié où
toutes les précautions sont prises
pour que l'accueil des patients non
porteurs se fasse dans les meilleures
conditions afin que le risque de
contamination soit totalement éviter il
ne doit donc pas y avoir de renoncement
aux soins indispensables
il est important que les médecins qui
suivent des patients chroniques et
détecte des risque de décompensation
parmi ces patients les plus fragiles
puissent entrer en contact avec leurs
patients partez des consultations par
vidéo par téléphone et bien sûr ils
seront rémunérés pour ses actes nous
avons facilité la délivrance de
médicaments en pharmacie
même avec une ordonnance expiré le suivi
infirmier a été prolongée et de recours
à la téléconsultation a été facilitée il
est indispensable de poursuivre tous les
actes préventifs comme le suivi des
nourrissons avec la vaccination
obligatoire indispensable contre des
maladies infectieuses à haut risque mais
également le suivi des femmes enceintes
il faut respecter au mieux le calendrier
des examens médicaux obligatoires
les médecins les sages-femmes mais aussi
les infirmières puéricultrices les pmi
toulouse ont un rôle important à jouer
depuis le confinement
certains pourraient être évités au
craindre d'appeler le 15 qui est le
numéro des urgences médicales
la prise en charge des détresses vitales
et la priorité des samu et le centre 15
répond il est donc indispensable
d'appeler le 15
si vous avez des douleurs thoraciques
des signes neurologiques évocateur
d'accident vasculaire cérébral ou des
signes de détresse vitale vous le savez
nous sommes très attentifs à nos
personnes âgées à nos aînés et les ehpad
en particulier vers une période très
particulière de fortes tensions
les personnes âgées sont les plus
fragiles face au virus en collectivité
malgré tout le professionnalisme et
l'engagement déployés la contagion est
souvent plus importante pour faire face
à l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
âgées atteintes du coc u19 les ehpad ont
besoin de renfort je les invite donc à
remonter le plus vite possible leurs
besoins aux agences régionales de santé
avec des détails avec des expressions
précises pour que nous leur trouvions
rapidement et collectivement des
solutions
la réserve sanitaire peut apporter de
l'aide
comme les plateformes régionales de mise
en relation entre les établissements
médico sociaux et les volontaires nous
mettons tout en oeuvre pour permettre à
nos aînés de bénéficier du meilleur
accompagnement possible et
accompagnement humain en cette période
si difficile pour nos aînés santé
publique france a mobilisé 50
réservistes de la réserve sanitaire pour
venir renforcer les ehpad des régions
centre val de loire occitanie hauts de
france auvergne rhône-alpes une
mobilisation de grande ampleur de
réserviste au profit des ehpad d'île de
france est en cours de déploiement et
sera effective à compter de demain 50
ehpad sur les huit départements
franciliens vont bénéficier de ces
renforts
j'appelle tous les professionnels de
santé libéraux ou salariés et ceux de
l'accompagnement à domicile qui font un
travail formidable au quotidien et dont
l'activité pourrait être réduite du fait
de l'épidémie et du confinement à se
porter volontaires davance un immense
merci à toutes et tous une question pour
faire mars et pharmaceutiques concernant
le déconfinement progressive
va-t-on vers un déconfinement par région
classe d'âge facteurs de risque ou en
combinant les 3 alors je vous le dis ce
soir nous ne sommes pas encore au pic
puisqu'il y à tous les soirs un peu plus
de balades en milieu hospitalier et tous
les soirs un peu plus de malades à
prendre en charge en réanimation nous
avons atteint un niveau jamais atteint
en france
donc nous ne sommes encore qu'à la phase
ascendante de l'épidémie même si elles
ratent ralenti un peu et donc aborder
aujourd'hui le déconfinement n'a aucun
sens ce premier ministre l'a dit nous
devons être absolument mobilisés sur le
confinement les gestes barrière la
distanciation sociale et le temps du
confinement n'est pas venu donc c'est
vraiment important que tout le monde ait
compris nous avons absolument besoin
d'un respect strict du confinement on
voit qu'on est aujourd'hui à une
mobilisation totale maximale
de nos capacités de réanimation un
relâchement serait extrêmement dangereux
pour les patients pour les soignants et
c'est parce que nous avons besoin de
préserver notre système de santé que les
français doivent être très attentif au
respect du confinement
le temps viendra de discuter du
déconfinement mais aujourd'hui nous
devons tout faire pour passer ce pic une
question pour france info
dans le registre des formes graves déco
vie 19 en cours d'élaboration il
semblerait qu'un réanimation plus de 80
% des admis sont en surpoids ou obèses
est ce que vous confirmez alors ce sont
des données qui remontent de plusieurs
sources scientifiques
ce sont des données d'observation aussi
il y a effectivement très souvent un
facteur de risque retrouvez dans les
infections virales grave ça a été
démontré dans la grippe particulier un
lien entre le surpoids et la survenue de
formes sévères
donc effectivement attention nous sommes
très attentifs à ce que les personnes en
particulier en surpoids important signal
rapidement une détérioration de leur
état clinique et en particulier
l'apparition de difficultés
respiratoires
on le sait le l'obésité d'une part mais
même le surpoids peut devenir un facteur
de risque d'infection sévère une
question pour france inter pouvez vous
nous donner le nombre exact des passes
de touché avec au moins un cas kobe 19
confirmer donc testé alors je vous ai
donné le nombre exact de d'établissement
qui signale je vous ai dit que ce soir
4553 établissement avait signalé au
moins un cas de co vide
parmi ces établissements qui sont des
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
il y à 2958 ehpad et je voudrais aussi
expliquer aux français que les ehpad qui
ne déclarent pas ne sont pas des ehpad
qui ont des cas mais qui ont oublié de
déclarer toutes les ehpad signal et donc
il ne faut pas multiplier le nombre de
cas par le nombre des pattes ça n'aurait
pas de sens puisque aujourd'hui on a
mobilisé très largement toutes les
époques pour leur dire de bien signaler
sur toute la période de l'épidémie tout
cas d'infection est évidemment tout
décès donc on n'est pas dans une phase
où on a oublié la moitié ou les deux
tiers des ehpad il y a fort heureusement
et c'est important que les français le
sachent
encore une majorité de départ qui n'ont
pas de cas qui n'ont pas eu à ath à
souffrir du coronavirus ccc ehpad en
particulier
que l'on souhaite préserver que l'on
souhaite protéger au mieux ou le
confinement doit être stricte en
particulier confinement en chambre ou le
personnel doit être attentif et vous le
savez le ministre des solidarités de la
santé s'est engagé à prioriser a donné
toute priorité aux ehpad et donc nous
avons là encore les instructions très
claires pour que les ehpad puissent
signaler sur leur territoire toute
suspicion de cas et bénéficier de tests
très rapidement une question pour cnl
monsieur vers a expliqué aujourd'hui que
la doctrine d'état qu'on sent dans l'
usage démasquant population en général
n'avait pas changé
pourtant de nombreux élus locaux
s'équiper devant le port du masque
obligatoire
la président de la région bourgogne
franche comté affirmé mardi que deux
millions de masques elle avait commandé
pour sa région avait été réquisitionnée
par l'état à même le tarmac y at il deux
politiques en conflit celle de l'état et
celle des régions
pas du tout et la doctrine est
extrêmement claires les masques
soignants sont réservés aux soignants et
l'état a toujours été clair sur ce point
en particulier pour les masques ffp2 qui
sont réservées aux actes invasifs et
pour tous les soignants le masque
chirurgical
ensuite il y a effectivement aujourd'hui
de plus en plus grâce à la production
française de masques non soignants les
français n'ont jamais porter de masque
dans l'histoire récente
si les français veulent notamment ceux
qui sont exposés notamment les
professionnels qui ont des activités de
contacts dans lesquelles ils ne peuvent
pas garder la distance dans lesquels ne
peuvent pas éviter les rassemblements
disposer de masquer ce sera un outil de
plus mais je rappelle et c'est très
important que le jour où il y aura des
confinement qui n'est pas arrivé il y
aura de toute façon à garder les mesures
barrières les mesures de distanciation
sociales la réduction des contacts et il
ne faut surtout pas imaginer que le
masque et la remet une arme unique
d'ailleurs vous savez que les débats
scientifiques se poursuivent ce n'est
pas un débat de la dgs ou du mit sa la
santé c'est un débat aux états unis
c'est un débat en europe et sa taille
bas au sein de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
le directeur général de lot de l' oms de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
même re dit son inquiétude sur le fait
que pour certains
l'accès aux masques pouvait signifier
l'abandon de toutes les autres mesures
barrières et ce serait une erreur donc
il ne faut pas prendre le masque au menu
une assurance contre le virus puisque je
vous rappelle qu'il se transmet par les
mains souillées par des hommes
soulier d'où l'importance de se laver
les mains très régulièrement qui se
transmet par un contact au cours duquel
on ne fait pas attention et on peut se
contaminer notamment en se touchant le
visage et donc il faut qu'on soit tous
attentifs à bien différencier les
masques soignants qui sont en priorité
pour les soignants le masque p2 le
masque chirurgical
et puis un jour peut-être un accès à des
masques que la france est en train de
produire qui sont des masses destinés à
des non soignants et dont on verra tous
ensemble la doctrine d'utilisation une
question pour le généraliste le syndicat
mg france estime sur la base d'une
enquête auprès de 2000 médecins de en
deux familles que plus de 1 million de
patients et été vus pour kobe 19 dans
leurs cabinets du 17 mars au 3 avril
allez vous prendre en compte ces
chiffres ou disposez vous d'autres
indicateurs pour mesurer la population
infectée
alors c'est exactement ce que l'on
souhaite estimé est modélisé comme vous
le savez il y à une forte mobilisation
de la médecine de ville du premier
recours pour prendre en charge des
infections qu'ovide et nous allons
utiliser la proportion de personnes
hospitalisées
la proportion de létalité céda
finalement la part de personnes qui
décèdent l'activité de ville qui est
d'ailleurs estimée par santé publique
france qui publie régulièrement un point
épidémiologique hebdomadaire
pour avoir une idée par ces données
épidémiologiques d'une part mais aussi
par des premiers résultats d'études de
sérologie dans certaines banques de sang
on a avec des donneurs de sang ou avec
des professionnels de santé volontaires
toutes ces études sont en cours pour
estimer qu'elle est la part de la
population qui a rencontré le virus et
qui est donc immune il une question pour
l'usiné nouvelle comment évolue la
situation pour les produits
anesthésiants et quelles actions
concrètes ont été engagées face au
risque de pénurie mobilisation totale
puisque vous comme vous l'imaginez bien
et je les ai déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises tout l'environnement du malade
le plus grave doit être sécurisé c'est
le cas évidemment en premier des
renforts humains de la présence de
médecins spécialistes en réanimation
médecine intensive réanimation
anesthésie d'être d'un terne d'ex terme
de deux infirmiers spécialisés des
soignants et de tout le plateau
technique
donc tout ça est évidemment sécurisée
nous avons sécurisé les respirateurs
nous
donner accès aux consommables et puis il
ya aussi les médicaments indispensables
pour l'anesthésié pour la réanimation
pour lesquelles les demandes ont
fortement augmenté partout dans le monde
et vous savez que le marché du
médicament et mondiale que les matières
premières viennent de très nombreux pays
et donc nous avons une démarche
européenne nous avons une démarche
française d'aller chercher les
médicaments là où ils sont et donc de
faire des commandes urgentes et
importantes pour ses produits
indispensables
ça c'est la montée puis en aval il
s'assurer qu'il ya une collaboration
parfaite une solidarité parfaite entre
établissements pour le prêt de ses
flacons puisque des établissements de
chirurgie par exemple qui ont ce type de
flacons pour leur bloc opératoire
peuvent les prêter peuvent les donner
aux établissements qui font de la
réanimation actuellement puisque
aujourd'hui vous savez nous avons
déprogrammé toute l'activité de
chirurgie non urgente une question pour
ces news est ce qu'on peut considérer
certains problèmes dermatologiques comme
l'urticaire par exemple comme de
nouveaux signes ducobu 19 pas à ma
connaissance mais comme vous le savez
nous apprenons chaque jour sur ce virus
et certains décrivent des formes qui
n'étaient pas connus mais sur cet aspect
dermatologiques je n'ai pas vu de
publication une question pour rtl
certaines villes restreignent les
horaires des joggings cela ne
risque-t-il pas de concentrer les
coureurs tôt le matin ou tard le soir
alors l'objectif je vous rappelle du
confinement c'est de réduire les
contacts donc tout doit être fait dans
votre activité quotidienne et c'est
surtout ça le message à passer pour
réduire les contacts
on voit bien que certaines personnes
sont obligées de sortir pour faire leurs
courses ont obligé de sortir pour aller
travailler sont obligés de sortir pour
rendre visite à une personne fragile ou
vulnérables pour laquelle elles rendent
des services mais en permanence quelle
que soit votre activité finalement vous
devez avoir l'obsession de réduire les
contacts
donc c'est pas tellement une question
d'heure c'est pas une question de jour
ou de nuit c'est d'être attentif lorsque
l'on sort à avoir le moins de contacts
possibles et en particulier de respecter
toujours cette distance minimale de m
des questions pour la paix m les mesures
de confinement peuvent-elles être
néfastes à long terme risque
cardiovasculaire risques psychologiques
et autres est il pertinent de concentrer
les heures de jogging alors les mesures
de confinement on le sait sont parfois
mal tolérés
et le premier ministre et président de
la république le disent régulièrement
ils savent que c'est un sacrifice pour
beaucoup que c'est difficile à supporter
mais c'est indispensable si nous voulons
passer tous ensemble cette période
extrêmement difficile qui nous met en
tension absolue nos systèmes de santé et
nos établissements de santé en
particulier puisque comme vous le voyez
il ya ce soir plus de 7000 personnes en
réanimation alors que la capacité
initiale de réanimation en france de
5000 lits dont vous imaginez combien les
efforts des établissements santé publics
et privés ont porté leurs fruits puisque
nous avons doublé en quelques jours la
capacité de l'animation en france mais
il ne faudrait pas car relâchement du
confinement aboutisse à une nouvelle
vague avec à ce moment là des
difficultés de prise en charge des
malades les plus graves une question
pour le figaro des médecins de la région
grand test témoignent de difficultés à
s'approvisionner en médicaments
essentiels en soins palliatifs en
pharmacie de vie notamment au rivotril
autorisé par an récent décret en
médecine de ville des pharmaciens m'ont
confirmé que le rivotril est en état de
rupture fabricants dans la région quel
est l'état des stocks de ces médicaments
en officines de ville
allez-vous mettre en oeuvre des mesures
pour assurer l'approvisionnement des
médecins chargés d'accompagner les fins
de vie
oui c'est absolument ce que nous faisons
actuellement et nous avons trouvé des
solutions
c'est pas uniquement sur le rivotril ce
sont d'autres molécules pour que l'accès
aux soins palliatifs parce que là on
parle de prise en charge spécialisée de
l'équipe mobile dédié aux soins
palliatifs se fasse dans les mêmes dans
les meilleures conditions qu'il n'y ait
pas de rupture d'accès à ces produits
indispensables pour la prise en charge
palliative des personnes qui ont besoin
de soins spécifiques
une question pour vl médias pouvez vous
faire un point sur les stocks de gel
hydroalcoolique des commandes ont elles
été passé
selon vous la production nationale
arrivera-t-elle prochainement couvrir
les besoins des soignants et du grand
public
oui ma connaissance il ya eu une très
forte production de multi source de
solutions de l'alcoolique et nous ne
sommes plus en difficulté sur ce sur cet
axe et solutions hydro-alcooliques une
question pour hospimedia une lettre
ouverte de plusieurs médecins à edouard
fidi propose d'intégrer pleinement dans
le système de santé les praticiens à
diplôme hors union européenne pas dû est
il possible d'en savoir plus sur les
mesures envisagées pour ses produits
dans le contexte de crise sanitaire
alors il est déjà ils sont déjà
gray dans beaucoup de réponse d'urgence
et donc c'est un sujet depuis longtemps
c'est un sujet de dax est effectivement
de praticiens en soutien à l'activité et
à l'offre de soins en france donc c'est
un sujet que nous traitons de la même
façon que nous traitons aussi vous le
savez de façon européenne l'accès aux
médecins qui ont un diplôme européen
une question pour rfi avez-vous des
statistiques sur les patients atteints
de kovy 19 admis en réanimation est
sorti par la suite
alors nous avons des statistiques
puisque les réanimateurs en france ont
l'habitude depuis des années de faire
des statistiques très précises sur
l'activité de réanimation simplement
compte tenu de l'activité intense de
réanimation nous ne disposons pas encore
de ces statistiques précises vous avez
vu que l'essentiel des patients de
réanimation est actuellement hospitalisé
c'est ça qu'il faut que les français
comprennent on a l'impression dans l'ain
dans la presse que l'épidémie est
presque derrière nous ce n'est
absolument pas le cas elle n'a jamais
été aussi présente avec un tel impact
sur les milieux hospitaliers sur la
réanimation et donc ces patients sont
souvent dans un état grave le pronostic
vital est engagé
ce sont des détresse respiratoire aigu
sévère qui nécessitent des soins lourds
des rede séjour en réanimation prolonger
parfois accompagnés d'autres détresse
raynal d'atteinte cardiaque par exemple
et donc tout cédé 13 font que le
pronostic est vraiment engagée que que
les efforts des animateurs sont majeurs
que la durée de séjour est prolongée et
quand sorti de réanimation souvent et
heureusement nous avons des places il y
à une indication assez jour de
réadaptation respiratoires motrices
cardiaque et donc derrière un séjour
spécialisé avant de rentrer à domicile
une question pour auteurs peut-on publié
le chiffre des cas confirmés en hôpital
et celui des cas annoncés pour les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
si ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi ces deux
totaux sont-ils données séparément comme
l'a fait olivier verrey hier alors je
sais pas si vous parlez des cas ou si
vous parlez des décès les cas annoncés
alors il y a objectivement aujourd'hui
plusieurs sources il y a le nombre de
personnes hospitalisées avec un cas
confirmé de coronavirus il y a les
sources de cas testés positifs en ville
donc ça aussi c'est à la fois l'hôpital
plus la ville et où les plus les
personnes qui ont eu des tests
positif et puis il ya les remontées des
ehpad qui sont encore différente puisque
les ehpad
on leur a demandé de signaler tous les
cas confirmés ou possible puisque quand
on a par exemple trois cas dans une même
elle du nepad
s'il ya un quatrième un cinquième cas on
considère que c'est encore un cas de
coronavirus et donc on inclut les cas
possibles et les cas confirmés ce qui
donne une idée plus précise de
l'épidémie dans les établissements
médico sociaux
je vous remercie et est la dernière
question merci à vous
[Applaudissements]